Опановуючи стрільбу з автоматів та кулеметів,
ці росіяни готуються нищити своїх співвітчизників на передовій в Україні - на боці ЗСУ.
Це друге комплексне тренування на Київщині так званого батальйону "Сибір".
Восени 2023 року стали відомі деталі про створення і підготовку цього нового спецпідрозділу ЗСУ.
До його складу входять громадяни РФ - представники різних корінних народів Росії:
здебільшого буряти та якути. Боєць "Малий" - з Уфи.
Втік з Росії після початку повномасштабної війни.
Стало ясно, що валити звідти треба, не вийде там жити.
Набрав кредитів, зібрав гроші і поїхав.
За кордоном є всілякі волонтерські центри, де сітки маскувальні шиють.
І там "хороші росіяни" приходять на один день і все.
Карму очистили і все. Для них достатньо.
Для мене це недостатньо. Для мене служити в лавах ЗСУ - оце робота.
Деякі з бійців батальйону "Сибір" вже навіть заговорили українською.
Державна мова в Україні українська, тому намагався вчити мову.
Я з самого початку війни вирішив, що хочу воювати за Україну.
Не хочу бути частиною фашистської імперії.
Мета - перемога України, звільнення України.
Що мотивує цих громадян Росії воювати на боці України?
Та Росія, яка знаходиться зараз у своїх межах, - це суперечливе поняття.
Росія і демократія неможливі.
Частина уламків, що відколються від Росії, там настане демократія.
Україна є маяком для Росії.
Український шлях дуже тяжкий, як я знаю з історії. Втім, вона змогла втриматися.
"Гріфін" родом з Уралу. Він ховає своє обличчя через страх за свою сім'ю, яка досі живе в Росії.
Я хочу залишитися в Україні, сподіваюся переконати дружину приїхати сюди, донька за кордоном.
Дружина боїться. Тому, я хочу приховати себе, якщо можна.
Крім представників корінних народів Росії, у батальйоні також служать також етнічні росіяни.
Один із них, Олексій Макаров, погодився відкрито спілкуватися з DW,
бо є доволі відомим російським активістом вже багато років.
Він корінний москвич. З 2011 року має політичний прихисток у Швеції.
До цього в РФ відбув тюремний термін за екстремізм як учасник
радикальної російської партії націонал-більшовиків.
Про цей епізод свого минулого чоловік говорить неохоче.
Ця скандальна екстремістська організація у 90-ті об'єднала прихильників російського імперіалізму.
Згодом переметнулася вліво на бік противників путінського авторитаризму.
У ці часи Олексій, власне, і вступив до цієї партії, але вийшов з неї в 2009-му після тюремного строку.
У 2014-му російські націонал-більшовики підтримали вторгнення РФ на Донбас і анексію Криму,
що обурило чоловіка і остаточно підтвердило: в РФ йому місця немає.
Я тоді пишався і зараз пишаюся українцями,
які змогли скинути режим, що прагнув влаштувати авторитарну систему, як у Путіна чи Лукашенка.
Мене це надихнуло.
У 2014 році мені здавалося, що достатньо того, що я в Швеції
проводив акції солідарності з політв'язнями Криму -
Олександром Кольченком і Олегом Сенцовим.
Збирав гроші, розповідав про арештованих в Криму.
Але в 2022 році під час повномасштабного вторгнення мені вже здалося, що цього недостатньо.
Олексій одним із перших доєднався до батальйону "Сибір".
До України зі Швеції чоловік переїхав ще у 2022-му,
брав участь у боях на харківському напрямку з українською штурмовою бригадою.
Каже, українські військові спершу ставилися до нього вкрай насторожено.
Були такі, які підходили до командира взводу і питали: "Для чого нам тут росіяни"?
Я потрапив у 95-ту окрему десантно-штурмову бригаду,
де мій старий український товариш, якого я знав з 2009 року, керував взводом.
Тоді було достатньо того, що командир взводу міг за мене поручитися, що я хороша людина.
Ну, і плюс мене перевіряли на кордоні при в'їзді в Україну.
Свою мотивацію воювати в Україні чоловік пояснює анархічними поглядами
та бажанням знищити існуючий лад в Росії.
Але не заради того, аби будувати в РФ демократичне майбутнє, а щоб усунути загрозу для безпеки Європи.
Якщо в Росії почнеться революція, я буду в ній брати участь.
Але саме повернутися туди - такої мрії нема.
У мене немає відчуття, що Росія - це мій дім.
Для мене критерій "свій-чужий" не визначається рамками державного кордону.
Він для мене визначається ідеалами і цінностями насамперед.
І в питанні цінностей я на боці України.
Ті, хто підтримав російське вторгнення, вони вороги, в яких треба стріляти.
Такі батальйони, як "Сибір", вважає Макаров, потрібні Україні на війні проти РФ
через те, що вони відстоюють інтереси окремих народів,
поневолених Москвою і зацікавлені у розвалі країни-агресора.
Мотивація інших угрупувань росіян в ЗСУ, як-от Російського добровольчого корпусу, Олексія не приваблює.
Російський добровольчий корпус був створений учасниками націоналістичного руху,
які декларують ідею етнічної вищості однієї нації над іншими.
Це неправильно.
А батальйон "Сибір" навпаки, він позбавлений всіх цих ідей.
Ми декларуємо принципи рівності всіх народів і права на самоврядування.
У керівництві батальйону запевняють: набір у "Сибір" відбувається вкрай ретельно.
Проходження поліграфів та інших перевірок може тривати до року.
Через це набрати повноцінний батальйон - тобто від 300 до 800 бійців - наразі ще не змогли.
Тож на практиці "Сибір" - радше неповна рота, тобто лише кілька десятків чоловік.
Побачив лінк на сибірський батальйон.
Подав заявку, через 15 хвилин дали відповідь.
Я був тоді в Стамбулі, в Туреччині.
І так мені відкрився коридор. Я написав в анкеті, що буду подаватися на громадянство України.
Наразі батальйон офіційно є складовою Міжнародного легіону
при Головному управлінні розвідки України.
У ГУР деталі рекрутингу, як і плани розширення "Сибіру" не коментують.
Відомо лише, що для участі в угрупуванні охочі їдуть в Україну через треті країни.
А по прибуттю тривалий час навчаються.
Ось з'явилася можливість, коли дізнався про "Громадянську раду".
Це така волонтерська організація, яка сприяє легальному потраплянню з Росії на територію України.
Там доволі складна схема. Але робоча.
Наскільки я знаю, охочих багато. Я, на жаль, цим не займаюся.
Я безпосередньо бойовий командир підрозділу.
Люди, які вже воювали, повертаються, рекрутів навчають, діляться досвідом.
Зараз тут на полігоні один тільки має бойовий досвід.
Дві групи, які не мають бойової практики, але є група більш підготовлена, є менш підготовлена.
Бо вони приїздили сюди в різний час.
Нещодавно угрупування повернулося зі свого першого бойового виїзду на Авдіївський напрямок.
За словами командира, росіяни пройшли бойове хрещення як штурмовики.
У мене перша група, та, з якою я виходив на штурм, вона в мене довго була.
Вони в мене навчалися майже 5 місяців. Я максимально їх підготував.
У нас без втрат, успішно виконали задачу.
Непідготовлених бійців ми не беремо на фронт.
У нас був стрілковий контакт з противником.
А потім уже в ході штурму, коли ми просувалися вперед, то був масований наліт дронів FPV.
Ось перше поранення в грудну клітину.
Олексій Макаров після бойового поранення проходить реабілітацію у Києві.
Коли його та побратимів знову відправлять на передову у складі ЗСУ - поки невідомо.